please welcome from our la studio max
greenfield
[Applause]
how are you i'm so good how are you
i'm doing well i like what you're
wearing it's a very annie hall vibe
it's great oh she's a bit of my style
icon so thank you so much
me too she's my style icon as well hair
makeup wardrobe is a
a very important step when you're
playing a part i agree when you get
really good people who are doing it all
of a sudden you realize when you get on
stage and you look at yourself in the
camera you're a totally different person
and then everything else is easy well
it's a funny segue
but one of the reasons i had brought
that up is because i was watching
i was looking at pictures of you and
your daughter
she had done a rainbow eye on you
and it's funny because my daughter olive
who's eight
just did a rainbow eye on herself
and it just looked so cool and i love
that you're the kind of dad that will
let your daughter
do makeup on you she loves makeup
um i it's beauty week on the on the show
this week right
it is in fact you're really kicking it
off oh well this is exciting
um i know they they showed me a bunch of
uh
stuff we have over here i thought you
could walk me through some of the
products and we could uh
we could apply some makeup i would love
it
drew what am i putting on first why
don't we start
with the eyes and by the way this is
all actually for your daughter so i'm
gonna send you
a fresh kit for her so that it's all
brand new and perfect i'll have that to
you later today
this by the way this stuff looks so nice
the packaging is very nice i don't know
what any of it is but it looks great
we make all the packaging i've been
doing this business for
nearly a decade you know what i'm just
going to have you do it with a finger
finger yeah there's a famous makeup
artist named pat mcgrath and she does
everything with her finger
sure i love pat dig your finger in
relatively strongly
and then just go right on your eyelids
uh-huh okay now i want you to go like
it's a deodorant on your cheekbones
now we're talking yeah good perfect
now i'm to move on to lips find
where your middle point is and then work
left or right
[Laughter]
yes
max how do you like making the
neighborhood it's such a
powerful um amazing
um show in its format
and it's like in its tone uh
thematically the storyline well we have
a really wonderful group of writers
um i know let me let let's let's address
this
maybe we should have done this question
first
i'm literally thinking the same thing
um we're just really happy to be back
for a season
you really like rolled through the
question that i go oh we're go okay
we're going in it
and then i could i could just disregard
what's happening
which may have been the move okay i
could have switched
questions um i will just i will simply
answer it with this
we have an incredible incredible group
of people
on that show um from jim reynolds who
created the show
who's on big bang theory forever cedric
the entertainer
who really is so much more than just
an actor on the show he's a producer on
the show and really crafts
every story and makes sure that the
butler family is represented
in an organic authentic way to sheena
arnold who has been on tv forever and is
probably the most talented sitcom
actress i've ever worked with
um everyone on the show from top to
bottom beth bears who plays my wife who
i love
marcel spears gian mckinney like it's
just a great great group
max may i ask how do you feel
when your daughter is doing makeup on
you like what goes through your mind
she's gotten really good at making sure
like come out
she'll do it in the morning where she
has like a half hour between breakfast
and her zoom school
and then she'll be like check out what i
just did
and we'll go you can't be on your zoom
for school with a full face of makeup
having said that
you did a really good job and we're very
good but you need to take it off
seems like you're exactly what a female
needs
like you're fun you're empowering
you're humorous your playful like you
really are the complete package and
yeah my wife's my wife's somewhere just
like this
how did you guys meet may i ask we
got oh my we met in 2003
and it was just like out at a club
i love it yeah well i usually was never
allowed into those clubs or bars and i
finally got into one and i was like
what's that i gotta i gotta find
something in here but also
max i think you're gonna like give a
little like
delusion to women that they think if
they're gonna go to a club and meet a
man like you
i think you're going to give women a lot
of hope no no no no
one you're giving me too much credit and
two i've met a woman who has
just uh really through many different
uh techniques changed me in a lot of
different ways
well max i am just thrilled to be
hanging out with you today
what a great way to kick off this week
with a man who is fun
and good to hit the women in his life i
think that is
important for beauty well i appreciate
it and
i'm so happy to be here and to meet and
sit with you and this has really been
special and great and obviously
rewarding thank you
max greenfield uh the season premiere
of the neighborhood is tonight on cbs
and airs
mondays 8 7 central thank you max again
so much for being here
[Music]
you